from a dating perspective if you had to  pick a CEO that had to run your company  for the rest of your life and all of  your success was predicated on that one  pick how many different CEOs would you  interview a shitload but when people  like want to pick their spouse that  they're going to be with for the rest of  their life they uh go on like seven  dates and they're like this one's good  enough I think people pick wrong I know  that's not a very acceptable stance for  a lot of people because they're like I'm  in this marriage what do I do I'm like  well what if you hired somebody and it's  not working out you do everything you  can but at a certain point like that's  why I like you pick better next time and  ideally you spend a lot of time trying  to pick right in the beginning if we had  no feelings for each other would this  still make sense which I think is a  really good question to ask